[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show why do they do that because we
challenge them yes we tell our viewers I
dare you to find one small mistake in
this perfect show I know we should call
it fun Corrections because it's fun to
shoot him down I had the whole weekend
to work on that yeah well I thought I
thought for two so far as you know Andy
hundreds and hundreds of challengers not
one winner
we don't make mistake yep well tonight a
fan named Dean thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened when I was
talking about the recent discovery of
water on Mars take it away Dean hey
Conan my name is Dean the other night I
was watching your show and she was
talking about science discovering water
on Mars rush limbaugh has said this is
real that the evidence of water on Mars
is all part of a leftist agenda limba
also said that a hydrogen atom bringing
two oxygen atoms together to make water
is pretty gay however one hydrogen and
two oxygens is not the correct
proportion for water we all know that
water is h2o if you have one oxygen and
two hydrogen's not the other way around
they will combine in a perfect
proportion and form water you should
probably stick to comedy and leave
chemistry to people like me
[Music]
Dean you came on pretty strong even the
poster of Einstein behind you thought
you were laying it on a little thick put
on a lab coat I know yeah that is so
darling but I know he can use a remote
anyway I'm sorry Dean you got the lab
coat and you seem to be a smart kid but
you are dead wrong you see what I said
that night was absolutely 100% correct
but don't take my word for it I've put
together a team of 26 of the greatest
scientists in the world each one a
leader in his or her field who were
willing to go on the record and back me
up check this out
everyone knows that a water monster
contains two hydrogen atoms and one
oxygen but Mars the opposite is true a
water molecule on Mars contains one
hydrogen atom and two oxygen atoms we
are experts we know what we're talking
about
you are wrong wrong wrong wrong
[Applause]
that's why that's my favorite Neil
deGrasse Tyson quote one of his greatest
theory all right well the challenge
still stands you think you supported an
era when I show reporting a team
koco.com / haha I found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please